Vasek un projet sur Kamiya mis sur moi
maintenant c'est de gemme voir est le
Gauntlet Infinity assez puissant pour faire
oublier au monde Green Lantern ce qui
va résoudre ce problème en tant que pompe à condensateur de flux
la haine brise Thanos Alleluia 1980
Ryan si pot mort pour choisir un  Le
costume d'Halloween serait-il Thanos câbler un
menton violet ou un faux bras et un
œil rouge Je vais aller avec le
sac à dos violet un faux bras et un œil rouge Je
vais aller est fable
Hugo s Josh qui est le pire super-héros
Deadpool et x-men origines origines
Wolverine ou Green Lantern Green Lantern
parce qu'il est le pire acteur, n'est-ce pas Ryan
Gosling Ryan, ne pensez-vous pas qu'un
Ryan talentueux suffit pour le Canada,
c'est pourquoi on m'a demandé de partir
oh c'est de Matteo D  quel Avenger
me recruteriez-vous x-force c'est une bonne
question je prendrais probablement Hawkeye
parce que je pense que je parle pour tout le monde
quand je dis où est le [ __ ] de Hawkeye
Josh le paresseux était plutôt moche dans les
Goonies c'est de Frank V au fait
mais  vous  d'accord le Deadpool est le
plus moche de tous merci et merci
Frank V pour ta question merci
franchement pour ta question je veux
regarder Frank D pendant un moment hey Frankie
merci mec ouais merci pour cette question
je suis en train de faire pipi  en ce moment par
jean-claude deuce Ryan as-tu vraiment
vraiment dansé avec Céline Dion peux-tu
chanter et faire un duo avec des cendres avec Josh tout d'
abord ce qui est des cendres des cendres est la
chanson de Céline Dion bienvenue dans l'émission Josh
[Musique] à l'
envers encore de
I'm in  la vidéo je fais des trucs dedans
mais le gars qui fait la
danse brillante est l'un des vôtres c'est un gars
de France nommé Yanis Marshall qui est un
danseur très très doué et l'une des personnes les
plus drôles que j'aie jamais
rencontrées c'est Deadpool  - pas Titanic ici tu
commences bien question suivante il y a un super
casting dans ce film mais on peut s'attendre
à voir la Licorne
ouais d'où vient la Licorne je n'ai pas vu
le premier Deadpool une créature mystique
qui vit dans notre imagination et
c'est dans  les  premier film whoops
vous n'étiez pas censé voir que la
licorne apparaît quelque part dans ce film
la seule partie du premier film que j'ai vue
est quand vous avez mentionné le câble à la fin
ouais je connais la partie qui est la
meilleure c'est que c'était quoi  vraiment
envoyé à la maison poney souterrain Howard
Deadpool vaincre Thanos s'il faisait partie
des Avengers c'est une excellente question
J'éteindrais probablement l'ordinateur qui l'a
fait Ryan portez-vous des chaussettes Hello Kitty
sous le costume de Deadpool
portez-vous des chaussettes Hello Kitty à droite  maintenant, la
réponse est non, je porte une combinaison lavande Hello Kitty,
mais avec de petites
taches dorées sous ce que je porte aujourd'hui,
c'est notre licorne dr.  Keenan Dr.  Kino le
tatoueur n'a-t-il pas l'air d'un
tatoueur vilain vilain non ouais
Ryan tu t'es moqué du look de Josh dans les
Goonies tu t'es moqué de Josh l'
année dernière il n'y a pas je rajouterai mais tu l'as
vu en raclée c'est beaucoup  pire
ce que le [ __ ] de dr.  Kino je veux dire quoi de neuf
mec revenez juste à donner aux gens l'
hépatite dans les tatouages ​​c'est de booboo
a 77 Josh alors que vous venez du futur
tout le temps soit comme ça d'
accord d'accord
la réponse est nuageux avec une chance de
te faire [ __ ] David D Josh Ryan  est-ce que tout est
écrit et verrouillé avant le tournage ou
pouvez-vous improviser unset absolument
tout est logarithmique verrouillé solide
il n'y avait pas d'improvisation ou d'
improvisation dans ce film je n'avais aucune idée de
ce qui se passait quand j'étais autour de Ryan
Reynolds je ne sais pas  ce qu'il disait
je ne sais pas ce qui a fini dans le film
ce qui n'a pas fini dans le film je n'ai
aucune idée de quoi parlent les films et nous avons
fini à temps c'est tout ce qui importait à Josh
ok c'est de notre PC un 831
le nom le plus long de tous les temps
Josh pouvons-nous nous attendre à ce que Goonies filme
à l'avenir absolument absolument
Je veux dire Al Pacino et Robert De Niro dans
Goonies to Goonies to war espère que
Meryl Streep goodies n'ouvrira pas payez-moi appelez
10 Cortana rideau on dirait qu'il
sait e  à c'est une épée Ryan eh bien pouvons-
nous nous attendre à plus de films Deadpool après
celui-ci quand voudriez-vous arrêter oh
mon Dieu merci je voulais juste arrêter
pendant un siècle mais je ne sais pas si
nous pouvons nous attendre à Deadpool après  celui-
ci, nous le verrons, cela dépend si vous le
voyez ouais vous devez le voir d'
accord, ils ne feront probablement même pas
trois
ouais pourquoi l'arrêteraient-ils - vous l'avez
tué avant ouais
memcache nivelle un ute Vecchio
en faisant correspondre à Terry  Deadpool assume
Georgia en la correspondant cet hiver
Cheyenne Shafran wha
Josh Valhalla n'est pas une nouvelle
quand je peux adapter des merveilles tu sais
Annie
Oh Beast n'appelle pas ça un retour
Je l'ai battu en
snowboard, il devrait y avoir un
seau bien sûr si je le sais, mais pour
bien savoir, c'est si vous faites savoir si
ce poste les nouveaux uniformes ont l'air fabuleux les
gars un peu ce rouge est votre couleur numéro
deux
sûrement beaucoup c'est fou
pensez-y comme un travail d'équipe les clés pour le
garder s  ubtle pense à cela comme un
cadeau spécial Deadpool pour vos 659 millions de
fans dans le monde
[Music]
[Applaudissements]
querida
jour sans pénis quoi dans le Pogba ils
ne portent pas les genouillères officielles de
Deadpool Je sais qu'ils ne portent pas de genouillères
mais ils sont sûrs comme  faire maintenant
j'aurai la tête de Josie pour cette somnolence je
vois quand vous faites une suite vous devez
doubler dans vos promotions ou vous
venez d'être enterré par la guerre à l'infini pourquoi vous
savez que la nourriture caféine famiglia
allons vous faire sortir les garçons ce soir voir le
planètes Maccabées arabes sajama
ce n'est pas difficile de
nous développer c'est en dehors de vos pieds
pâte moelleuse gcvideo
élaborer sur le haut sifflet soufflant
sauvignon aah optimisme programme de fermeture à glissière LED
sexe un acacia mushmelon obtenir un ennemi
max Ehrmann je suis vraiment très occupé à faire
des trucs et ouais ouais  ne m'accorde pas
trop d'attention c'est pourquoi je ne peux pas être
là
[Musique]